you know you rewind gee it's over ten
years now I was a newly minted MBA my
background was in tech but I found
myself I was an analyst at a small hedge
fund in Boston and I had some family
visiting me in particular one member 12
year old cousin Nadia and just came out
a conversation that she was having
trouble with math and so I dug a little
bit deeper and it turned out that she'd
taken a placement test at the end of
sixth grade there's a lot of unit
conversion on it she claims she didn't
understand you didn't version and
because of that they put her into a
slower math track so when I heard that I
said hey Nadia how about when you go
back home she was lived in New Orleans
which is where I was born and raised I
can tutor you over the phone or over
instant messenger or something and she
agreed so I started tutoring her this
was fall of 2004 and long story short
she learned unit conversion and then I
started to teach her a little bit more I
started teach her some algebra and she
actually went from being behind her
class to being ahead of her class and
you know at that point I choked I became
a tiger cousin and I called up her
school I said I think Nadia Rahman
should retake that placement exam and
they said who are you and I said I'm her
cousin they let her and she went from
the the slower math class all the way to
the advanced math class and so there's
something here I this is a small
intervention just for a few weeks with
someone I cared about so I then started
working with her younger brothers and
then you fast forward two years two
things happen one word got around the
family that free tutoring was going on
so I found myself with on the order of
10 or 15 cousins and family friends
every day after work around the country
and I was getting on conference calls
with them and whatnot and I also started
building software for them to make sure
that they had a strong foundations and
things like basic arithmetic fractions
decimals exponents and that software
that I was making for them that gave
them as much practice as they needed and
solutions and a way for me as their
tutor to keep track of what they were
doing that was the first incarnation of
Khan Academy that's when I got the
domain name khanacademy.org and at that
point it had absolutely nothing to do
with videos and even then
just view that as a hobby and I was kind
of running this website and I it was fun
for me to hack on the software but then
you fast forward a little bit more
around 2008 that I certainly this is I
started thinking this is a real thing
and I'm sleeping and there's some kid in
Indonesia who is learning algebra like
this there is something real here and
there's a real need that's being met I
wasn't sure whether there's a business
model here in fact I didn't want there
to be a business model on it I wanted
people to understand that this is
something that I want it's social good
it's a it's something that should just
be out there a public good for the
planet and so in the early days of Khan
Academy I said one this I'm doing this
not because I want it to be a business
I'm doing this because I think it could
be a huge social good for the planet and
I want to do it in a way that is for
lack of a better word unkillable and in
fact it almost annoyed my my MBA friends
when they said hey Sal you know you're
doing all this stuff what's your
business model surely you have a
business I was like no no no I'm just
doing it for fun because they wanted you
know they wanted to push me on like hey
well if you they almost didn't want me
it some of them I didn't me almost
didn't want me to do it they're kind of
like well why is this guy doing this
thing if it didn't have some obvious you
know two year exit strategy type of type
of model but I think it really worked
well for for me for my mindset and for
Khan Academy to just keep going keep
making content being scrappy about it
doing whatever it took and at some point
it hits the traction and you start going
a lot faster and then to the outside
world it looks like an overnight success
but you know the real story you know
since this idea that we have at Khan
Academy one of our designers introduced
this idea you know it's this notion of
little bets and if you can you know that
working with Nadia that was a little bit
I was spending half an hour a day and
actually you know it was it was going to
be a win even if it didn't scale into
some you know huge global not-for-profit
organization reaching millions because
even that little bat was going to
benefit my cousin and I cared that she
went on a good trajectory and so I would
say whatever space you're in it doesn't
hurt in fact it you know there are
definitely people who don't who don't
take the do a little experimentation and
they they hit some traction they get
huge but I never hurts to really
understand the problem do it on a
on a more narrowly scoped understandable
way and see if some of your hypotheses
about this space are actually true and
then once you start getting validation
of these hypotheses then yeah you know
as they say nail it and then scale it
and you don't have to wait for it to be
completely nailed but once you feel that
hey there's there's there I'm getting
some validation here enough for me to
invest more than you keep investing more
get more validation keep going